alors que depuis plusieurs jours denis
brogniart est particulièrement actif sur
les réseaux pour calmer les diverses
polémiques autour de koh lanta
voilà qu'un ancien aventurier a décidé
lui aussi de sortir du silence pour
pousser un immense coup de gueule contre
les producteurs du programme de tf1
c'est l'élimination de sam vendredi
dernier qui a fait déborder le vase
depuis des semaines plusieurs
aventuriers de la nouvelle saison de koh
lanta sont victimes sur les réseaux
sociaux d'insultés et de menaces de la
part d'internautes visiblement très en
colère sur son compte instagram denis
brogniart a poussé un coup de gueule je
voudrais vous dire mon dégoût ma
consternation
ma colère aussi devant les messages
haineux scandaleux reçu par certains
aventuriers je les ai cité régis inès
charlotte alexandra et bien sûr
auparavant ahmad alors dans quel monde
vit-on
comment peut-on menacé de mort insultes
et promettre le pire à des aventuriers
de koh lanta ça m'avait quand elle lui a
accepté de poster une vidéo dans
laquelle il demandait ses supporters de
garder leur calme et de se souvenir
qu'il ne s'agit que d'un jeu
aujourd'hui c'est pascal un ancien
aventurier présent dans le programme à
deux reprises en 2016 et 2018 qui a
décidé de prendre la parole
et d'accuser frontalement la production
du jeu d'être responsable de ces
comportements pour lui ce sont eux qui
par leur montage et leur manipulation
pousse les gens à la haine c'est des
images sont montés faut toujours un
méchant pour toujours des gens c'est
comme ça que ça marche
koh lanta aujourd'hui c'est un téléfilm
c'est une télé réalité toutes les
limites qu'on monte pour détester les
gens aimer les gens s'ils s'en prend
directement à l'échelle laroche joubert
productrice du programme
il explique que ces montages de la
production pourrait avoir des
conséquences graves
tôt ou tard à force de pousser de plus
en un mois pour faire du buzz et créer
une émission comme ça et faire de
l'action
il va y avoir un accident
un suicide il va y avoir des dommages
collatéraux aujourd'hui des personnes
sont en dépression et ça engendre
beaucoup de problèmes pour beaucoup de
monde des accusations graves à laquelle
la production n'a pour le moment pas
répondu
alors c'est vrai que ça fait un buzz
incroyable cette histoire de koh lanta
est ce que vous comprenez est ce que
vous trouvez que la pole à la production
est responsable de ces dérives ou pas du
tout voilà ce que la production at elle
provoqué la haine des téléspectateurs
envers des candidats en faisant un
montage un peu particulier benjamin
castaldi qui les en les lisant sont
d'une naïveté absolue les candidats ce
monsieur qui fait quand tu as deux fois
levé car ce n'est pas le principe n'est
pas le principe de la télé-réalité moi
je vous le dis depuis le début ce qu'on
montre à la télévision il ya un montage
effectivement on a un canevas maintenant
ce qui est montré on le producteur a
plaisir à oui alors lui je vais prendre
cette phrase là et puis non c'est pas
vrai effectivement ils sont dans
l'obligation de raconter une histoire a
effectivement ils vont grossir le trait
des uns et des autres mais arrêtez de
penser alors ouais je suis pas toujours
défendre les producteurs
mais voilà il ya un bail à faire est
depuis le début sur le loft on faisait
pareil avait il y avait la gentille avec
moi gentil y avait là on a toujours fait
ça et on fait ça donc tu veux vous dire
même dans l'info même dans le traitement
de l'info dans le montage c'est un peu
un peu le même phénomène est un meuble
le même principe quand on veut anglais
on angles et on dit ce qu'on a envie de
dire et voilà mais arrêtez d'être naïf
c'est comme ça depuis depuis 20 ans
cette chouette il ya plein de candidats
menacée notamment charlotte candidates
de cette cession qu'il est une des
candidates qui prend le plus sur les
réseaux sociaux lors d'un live ce
week-end elle est revenu sur les
critiques dont elle était la cible et
visiblement elle vit un vrai calvaire
regardez c'est dur ce qui est dit est
dit vous que derrière en fait il ya
aussi ma famille qui voit les messages
parce qu est-ce que vous par exemple
vous accepteriez de vous faire insulter
et votre famille en fait elle voit des
messages y perdure ouais c'était pas le
confinement
on aurait trouvé des trucs comme ça mais
des menaces mais bidon et
et en plus de personnes qui on sait même
pas si je peux en parler ou pas mais on
a un peu sur un moment on doit un peu se
canaliser demander pardon des choses
comme un an
vous êtes des fous alors ce qui a
provoqué ça c'est la vidéo d'élimination
de sam qui est à l'origine de la colère
des téléspectateurs et c'est vrai qu'à
des mais c'est ça prend des proportions
incroyables
est ce que la production est responsable
ou pas regarder ça me prenez votre sac
aller récupérer votre flambeau et venez
me rejoindre sam
les aventuriers de la tribu réunifiée
ont décidé de vous éliminer et leur
sentence est pire
c'est la fin d'un rêve d'un grand rêve t
auras claude m'a permis de vivre une
partie de mon rêve
j'ai été très content de faire des
épreuves avec vous le confort rectorat
j'espère vous voir triompher sur les
poteaux et la troisième personne qui
sera avec vous j'espère que ce sera là
où le meilleur sur le camp et sur les
épreuves
c'est très très dur que quand tu as un
mec aussi vite
et j'espère que que les autres vraiment
en profiter mais qui vont pas vivre leur
aventure affalé sur la plage attendre
que les journées passent là c'est
dommage parce que je sais que ma famille
croire en moi et je sais qu'ils seront
tristes ou moi alors si vous nous
rejoignez sachez que voilà c'est vrai
qu'ils aident énormément de menaces sur
les candidats de koh lanta suite à
l'élimination d'un candidat qui était
extrêmement aimé qu'ils gagnaient toutes
les épreuves c'est sam la production at
elle provoqué la haine des
téléspectateurs on verra les candidats
avec le montage qu'ils ont fait et c'est
oui ou non vous nous donnez votre avis
et gilles verdez oui alors je réponds à
benjamin et là je suis d'accord avec
bajaras sur le côté pascal royer dans le
sujet qui est très bon parce qu'à lui ne
pense qu'à faire le buzz comme il est un
peu en rupture irritable
mais sur le fond mais oui ce n'est pas
sur le fuyard donc oui oui absolument
mais sur le second pour ça vous dire oui
non pas du tout ses arguments sur le
fond il ya un problème si c'est vrai
c'est que la production depuis quelques
années attiré koh lanta vers une
émission de télé-réalité presqu'une
émissions d'enfermement où les
personnages sont stéréotypés
caricaturaux et donc on pousse le côté
négatif et on les incite à être un peu
plus méchant pile de son et sa base la
main c'est très récent sur koh lanta et
c'est vrai que donc on peut dire que à
force de faire des personnages très
méchant très stratège bien la production
un site appelé jean alors en vouloir
alors ils sont pas responsables des
menaces de mort sont paul mais si on en
veut un peu candidats de koh lanta
parce qu'ils ne viennent plus méchant
qu'il n'était avant très belle valérie
bénaïm vallée mais gilles jamain
ceinture découvre la foudre et que tu
découvres lanta n'est pas nouveau c'est
pas nouveau chez une tante may a eu des
gens qu'on adorerait dans koh lanta et
des gens ont été faits d'emplois et
depuis le numéro 1 de peinture vraiment
et c'est pas la production qui met le
stylo dans la main du des candidats en
disant mon bureau il faut que tu
élimines sam parce que ça va faire du
buzz mais non non c'est pas ça que c'est
pas ça qui est reproché à la production
valérie c'est le montage qui est fait en
fait c'est ça qui est beau rêver tout le
monde alors on le sait très bien
il y avait des personnages qu'on aime
des personnages qu'on aime détester des
personnages madoff lit à voix là mais
tout mais mais mais mais il ya des gens
oui mais pourquoi les candidats ce fait
ils disent qu'en frais qu'eux
et on vous montrent pas leur vrai visage
et compte un visage qui est voilà qui
est malgré donc ils prennent des iep
rennes des séquences et d'autres
séquences qui fut il reflète pas la
personnalité et ce qui fait qu'après ils
ont des problèmes sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est ça c'est ça le problème
gérald esprits alors lui n'est que parce
que d'abord effectivement effectivement
c'est un électron libre
c'est une grande fête toujours dis
jamais tu le bazar ça me plaît on se
souvient de sans précédent avec dylan et
yacine il avait prévenu prugnard il
avait une avec rick alexia laroche
joubert
effectivement il a un passif avec koh
lanta après pour ce qui est de koh lanta
aujourd'hui effectivement un feuilleton
de toute façon ces dates télé réalité
dont il ya le héros il ya le antihéros
il ya le jeune ya le vieux il ya le
gentil il ya le méchant il ya la jolie
kim est d'abord une sorte de culotte un
peu suggestives qu'on montre d'ailleurs
beaucoup beaucoup plus que les fesses
des autres des autres personnages des
autres candidats oui forcément
c'est de la télé c'est du spectacle donc
on feuilletait effectivement parfois les
défunts sont biaisés par exemple afin de
i've had bon on l'a vu par exemple quand
il est allé au bout du bout du truc là
vous du jura cour d'appel de l'épreuve
de force et du parcours merci valérie
donc effectivement les choses sont pour
le moins orienté mais moi je pense que
l'époque aujourd'hui
du coup chine mans où les gens regardent
les programmes les gens se défoulent sur
les réseaux sociaux je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les réactions ont été
encore plus à servir dans cet engagement
de défouloir comme ça quand on n'a plus
que ça et on dit bah allez ça on va nous
renvoyer en mettre plein la gueule à
celle là ou à celui là haskins énervé
parce que ça sent plus rien j'ai une
rigolade dans les mentions maintenant
j'ai un nouveau truc c'est que j'ai
l'impression qu'il y aille à mon daron à
côté de moi et tout les messieurs jo en
syrie qui m'a pas et alors chérissez
tous les mecs qui vont là dedans de
parole c'est pour ça que le jour où ils
vont être célèbre sylla moi j'ai horreur
de perdre
je mets jeu rare de perdre quoi jamais
je n'y arriverai d'un détruits ou un
gagnant et un perdant
si je perds je peux vous est d'accord
qui tu vas bien ses ventes chuter cas
neymar
je n'ai jamais cru à l'honnêteté de lune
télé réalité comme les mecs là le mec à
poil là je vous dis là j'ai tous et
toutes ces émissions de télé réalité
j'ai jamais cru à le mettre ces d'état
et ses titres en guise 6 e s qui voit là
on me prenait la responsabilité sans
faute puisque canal jeu que tu ne
maîtrises a pas main très bien la
version avoir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs sur koh lanta à regarder
ces partis merci sacha oui à 57 % de
l'oua 43%